let's get more now from Washington Post
columnist Eugene Scott good morning
Eugene good morning how are you let's
start with the shutdown here the
president says you know I didn't fold
but I mean I don't play poker was this a
full absolutely the president won its
5.7 billion dollars for his board of war
he didn't get it and there's a good
chance that he will never get it
Democrats are not on board with it and
an increasing number of Republicans are
not on board with so what happens over
the next 21 days because we're really
back to where we started when the
shutdown began I think what will be most
interesting is watching what happens
between Republicans in the next 21 days
we've already seen the number of
Republican lawmakers voting with
Democrats or at least pushing back
against Trump and one of the reasons
we're seeing that it's because the
Republican voters are pushing back
against Trump and it's very possible
that they will go to him and say look we
want border security just like you but
this wall we can't get support for it
has Nancy Pelosi managed to keep
Democrats United through this is that
solidarity gonna hold I think so
especially on this issue I mean even
before Nancy Pelosi became the house
speaker Democratic lawmakers were not
supporting this border wall obviously
because their basis weren't supporting
this border wall so this wasn't as hard
of itself for Nancy Pelosi as it was for
Donald Trump is there something
interesting about the dynamics of Nancy
Pelosi being the leader of Congress here
and and the fact that the president one
doesn't name call her has some level it
seems to have some level of respect for
her I mean is there an interesting
dynamic between the two of them that she
was able to like make this happen I
think there is a very interesting
dynamic if you recall after the midterm
elections when Democrats were fighting
about whether or not Nancy Pelosi should
be the house speaker
Trump was supportive of Nancy Pelosi
being the house speaker for a few
reasons and he tweeted about this one he
really does respect her she's been doing
this for more than 30 years and he needs
some villain he needs a rival he just
didn't realize that she was going to
beat him and beat him this badly the
reality though is if he wants to keep
his base which he is losing he's gonna
have to find ways to beat Pelosi at her
own game and this first battle he just
wasn't able to do that meanwhile we've
got 800,000 workers going back to work
getting getting back pay but is there a
is there a long-term call
of this shutdown absolutely I mean one
we know as of the 25th it was six
billion dollars to the to the economy
that's more than the 5.7 billion dollars
and the long-term cause I think that
Trump has to worry about this is
reputation he's already losing support
and most people a lot of people should I
say will not be getting back pay
security guards janitors cafeteria
workers contract contractors and we've
seen people I was reporting earlier this
week we've seen people who voted for
Trump who aren't going to vote for him
in 2020 because he's running on a
campaign called promises kept he hasn't
kept his promise the border was not
happening as of now and Mexico is
definitely not paying for it and things
could get worse this move by the
president in getting us to at least
reopen the government a response to what
was going on in the country or was there
some other reason did he know that he
was losing the base on this one I think
it was a response to the midterm 2018
elections he did not when he did not do
well we know that not only was there
Blueway there certainly was not a rare
wave and there were people who were
upset with him and some of his closest
advisers conservatives and talk radio
were saying that you have to stick to
what you said you would do and so he
really doubled down on this idea that
there was just no support for we don't
even have conservative think tanks
backing build the wall so obviously
people outside of his tribe weren't
going to get on board with it and ground
stoppages at the airport's might had
something to do with it - absolutely
Eugene Scott Washington Post thank you
thanks for having me